und bei mir im studio ist der
politikwissenschaftler professor tilman
mayer professor bayer erhalten sie denn
die union aktuell für arbeitsfähig
handlungsfähig so wie es gerade andreas
jung gesagt hat naja sie ist natürlich
in einem findungsprozess muss sich neu
fassen neu finden was die führung an
geht insbesondere da ist natürlich
einerseits jemand da laschet aber
andererseits noch ein zweiter söder und
vielleicht drumherum noch nicht
deklarierte auch anwärter auf eine rolle
eine herausgehobene ich denke
viele möglichkeiten
jedenfalls ist die partie natürlich
jetzt in ihrer identität nicht genau
fixiert und festgestellt sondern es ist
findet ein gewisses lavieren statt es
kann zu abstürzen kommen und insofern
ist diese woche natürlich sehr kritisch
es wird ja immer wieder gesagt herr jung
gerade auch oder alle unions politiker
die wir jetzt die letzten tage in
interviews gehört haben es geht jetzt
gar nicht ums personal es geht um
inhalte
aber gehört dass nicht auch irgendwie
zusammen und müsste nicht erst die
personalfrage geklärt werden und dann
über die inhalte gesprochen werden kann
ein parallel laufen also die
personalfrage ist natürlich insofern
entscheidend wenn es um die nummer eins
geht
unklarheit besteht wer führt dann den
ganzen laden wäre es denn verantwortlich
wenn darüber nicht einigkeit besteht
dann muss das natürlich irgendwie
bekommt solange mehr kurz als lang
geklärt sein und da in dieser phase sind
wir das natürlich über diese dinge jetzt
gesprochen werden muss dass man
sozusagen sich mit sich selber
beschäftigt die die partei und die
parteien ist in dieser phase finde ich
weil es ja dann um dieses programm für
die nächsten vier jahre geht schon
legitim ja jetzt muss man sehen was ist
da an substanz und worum soll es gehen
was wollen wir einbringen an inhalten
aber eben auch wie sie fragen an
personen und da ist natürlich die
kuriosität dass da vieles im angebot ist
fdp-vize kubicki hat gestern abend
gesagt am internet wird sich nicht mehr
halten können ergibt noch diese woche am
ende der woche wird er sich nicht mehr
halten können wie sehen sie das
das kuriose ist ja dass das budget schon
öfters passiert ist dass er da in einer
derartigen schwierigen konstellation war
und sich behaupten konnte also insofern
liegt einiges spricht einiges für dieses
urteil von kubicki aber andererseits ist
noch nicht aller tage abend er muss
natürlich jetzt noch ein paar hürden
nehmen und hier kann da jeweils stürzen
das ist natürlich schon erkennbar ist
das denn dieser strohhalmen nenne ich
jetzt mal jamaika
denen ja nach dem noch einige greifen
der dafür sorgt dass es jetzt nicht
völlig eskaliert und das nicht wirklich
ist ein aufstand gegen armin laschet
gibt das ist sicherlich richtig wenn
diese perspektive nicht bestünden müsste
man natürlich einfach sagen irgendjemand
ist ja für dieses desaster der union
verantwortlich und es ist eindeutig das
natürlich diese wahl von
laschet auf dem druck von schäuble
eine eine fehlkonstruktion gewesen ist
was damals behauptet wurde von seiten
der csu und sich dann natürlich
bestätigt hat auch die wahl der
zustimmung der csu in der bevölkerung
hat damit zu tun und so weiter und so
weiter dass wir alles klar aber es kommt
eben jetzt dieser punkt auf das jetzt
verhandelt werden muss insofern hat er
noch eine rolle und könnte sich sie
sagen strohhalm könnte sich daran
aufrichten
aber es würde voraussetzen dass
lindner sozusagen die kastanien aus dem
feuer holt in gestalt alt dass er sagt
das bündnis mit den grünen funktioniert
unter der führung der sozialist
sozialdemokraten nicht da ist das ist
natürlich viel verlangt wenn man so
denken würde insofern ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieser fall
eindeutig nicht allzu groß diese
hoffnung hat ja armin laschet lassen sie
uns noch über die rolle von markus söder
sprechen welches spiel spielt er jetzt
gerade gestern hat er ja wieder seine
spitzen gegen armin laschet verteilt
dann aber auch wieder von
geschlossenheit von gemeinschaft
gesprochen das ist der finne strategie
ja das ist ein gewisses changieren mit
dem ziel zu sagen ich bin derjenige der
dann das erbe antritt wenn hier irgendwo
etwas schief geht und nicht friedrich
merz oder röttgen und oder andere de
auch im anlauf sind sondern wenn es
darauf ankommt ist es ist mein spiel und
ich kann regierung bilden und deswegen
gebe ich eben vorgaben vor auf das
narrativ kommt es an und so weiter hat
ja inhaltlich einige punkte schon
genannt insofern ist er eine reserve
eine auffang position und das ist klar
erkennbar ob er dann die genügend
zustimmung bekommt in der fraktion
darauf games natürlich erstmal anderes
zu testen und die spd-bundestagsfraktion
hat inzwischen rolf mützenich als ihren
vorsitzenden bestätigte in der
fraktionssitzung in berlin stimmten nach
angaben eines pressesprechers
198 abgeordnete für mützenich es habe
vier nein stimmen und zwei enthaltungen
gegeben
herr professor bayer ist scheint ja
aktuell zumindest bei der spd alles
ziemlich glatt zu laufen ziemlich
reibungslos
anders als bei der union momentan ist
das denn das einzige
erfolgsrezept der sozialdemokraten
momentan ja es ist immerhin ein ganz
besonderes weil die sozialdemokraten ja
auch oft schon damit die öffentlichkeit
unterhalten haben dass sie sich heftig
streiten und nicht einig waren und
insofern kann man natürlich sehen die es
ist jetzt die wahl gewonnen und
irgendwann werden in gewisser weise die
rechnungen aufgemacht oder der preis für
das stillhalten verlangt dass das heißt
also die linke in der spd wird
irgendwann signalisieren dass sie
präsent ist und wird unterstützt werden
von der linken der grünen die das
ähnlich sehen und insofern kann da schon
noch eine gewisse turbulenz auftauchen
dann wird dieser zeitpunkt sein was
denken sie wie lange hält dieser frieden
ja das ist ab dem zeitpunkt wo natürlich
jetzt dann eingeschworen werden muss und
wo man sagt also jetzt machen wir das
bündnis mit der dieses ampelbündnis und
es kommt zu stande und so weiter
es kann nur im vorfeld natürlich
passieren dass die fdp sagt wir sehen
hier untiefen ungeklärte angelegenheiten
dann zieht sich diese sache natürlich
noch hin und dann müsste eigentlich die
linke wiederum entsprechend verschattet
werden und im dunkeln bleiben aber wie
lange sie da still hält ist natürlich
einfach die große frage wie bewerten sie
denn die aktuelle machtverteilung
innerhalb der spd und jetzt auch bei den
kommenden gesprächen das sind ja einmal
die beiden vorsitzenden und als einmal
der kanzlerkandidat und finanzminister
olaf scholz ja olaf scholz hat sich
natürlich sehr stark jetzt in den
vordergrund spielen können und die
anderen müssen ihn mehr oder weniger
assistieren die vorsitzende also eine
gewisse kuriose konstellation
die man sehr stark erklären muss dass
das sie ebenso entstanden ist wie man
das eben mitbekommen hat aber gerade vor
diesem hintergrund kann ich kann man
erwarten dass irgendwann eben dann doch
rechnungen aufgemacht werden und das
kann eigentlich durchaus bald eintreten
sie haben wir eben schon die fdp
angesprochen christian lindner hat
gesagt es fehle ihm die
vorstellungskraft welche angebote olaf
scholz der fdp machen können die
zugleich auch auf begeisterung der
spd-linken kevin kühnert und saskia
esken stoßen werden
ja also das ist natürlich
alles richtig und insofern müssen da
noch zeichen und wunder geschehen dass
das alles so läuft
was gerade eben gesagt wurde dass
natürlich gesellschaftspolitisch da
einiges machbar ist das ist sozusagen
geschenkt aber im bereich steuerpolitik
aber auch klimapolitik und wie man die
klimapolitik betreibt sind einfach
differenzen da die zum kern der fdp
philosophie gehören insofern muss man
eben natürlich auch stark auf die fdp
sehen denn grün schwarz grün rot ist
natürlich näher zusammen da kann was
passieren aber eben die rolle jetzt der
fdp ob sie hier auf ob da irgendwelche
ist vulkan ösis gelände ist auf dem sie
da läuft das wird man stark beobachten
müssen sie haben gerade das verhältnis
spd/grüne angesprochen wie eng ist das
denn tatsächlich also wenn man das jetzt
zum beispiel mit der fdp und union
vergleicht die scheint sich ja doch in
den vergangenen monaten jahren doch
engel gestanden zu haben als jetzt
eigentlich spd und grünen oder was er so
nah kleine wettbewerb auch weil die
grünen plötzlich so stark waren ja nicht
ich glaube es ist da ganz interessant
auf den hinweis von den baden
württembergischen ministerpräsidenten
von gestern hinzuweisen kretschmann hat
gesagt dass eben hier eigentlich dieses
schwarz grüne bündnis eine blaupause
wäre und es wird es kommt zum tragen
dass er eine reserve hat gegenüber den
sozialdemokraten und seine strategie ist
eigentlich für die grünen natürlich eine
spannende für die cdu eine gefährliche
denn schließlich ist er der
ministerpräsident und er hat es
geschafft diese große volkspartei zu
domestizieren
insofern ist also die frage für die
grünen und die spd ist da gibt es
weiterhin spannungsmomente nicht nur das
baden württemberg gesehen sondern eben
auch was die sozialpolitik angeht
von daher ist natürlich hier eine nahe
liegende position da aber noch nicht so
dass sie diese brücke begangen werden
kann